well Chaka Khan feels anything but love
for her fellow Divas in the music game
welcome everybody to Entertainment
Tonight We Love Shaka but she was not
pleased with Rolling Stone's
controversial list of the 200 greatest
singers of all time and she didn't hold
back Shaka pudding everybody through the
fire
[Music]
I believe it's going to be controversial
with you Mariah Carey number five yeah
that must be Paola or something like
that
so you're good with Mariah Carey no
no just ahead of You
[Music]
Adele at 22. okay I quit Debbie Harry
160. eight okay
Christina Aguilera 141
whatever a lot of black people like
Christina Aguilera she's all right
[Applause]
[Music]
little Funk who's won 10 Grammys landed
at number 29 on the list I've got five
generations in any given audience but
she's not the only one mad Celine Dion
didn't make the top 200 at all prompting
fans to protest outside the magazine
Rihanna's on the list at number 68 Dolly
Parton comes in at 27 Prince is 16 and
Beyonce ranks number eight however Shaka
really got going when she was asked
about her on and off again friend number
25 Mary J Blige they're good now I'm so
happy to be someone that could stand by
her and say I know her and love her I
love you too but Shaka said flat out
Mary J's cover of sweet thing was
bleeped up
[Music]
I said girl you don't sing nothing at
eight o'clock come on especially if you
have to get up to say it if you'd have
been up all night smoking crack or
something I don't know baby different a
whole different thing
Shaka was an all-negative telling Los
Angeles Magazine's podcast The Originals
she was good with Whitney Houston being
named number two and Aretha Franklin
deserved her spot is number one she
should be asking should be thank you
[Music]